at the tech X Expo in Silicon Valley
there's tremendous excitement over
artificial intelligence the influence of
AI right now is is really taking all the
air out of the room it's the only thing
that anybody cares about along with
enthusiasm for ai's possibilities
there's also concern over its impact on
jobs and the economy the majority of
people in the workforce come to work and
they do predictable things they do the
same kinds of things again and again
and once um you know algorithms or
robots are able to
learn from from data and figure out how
to do those things those jobs are
clearly going to be threatened
historically automation has replaced
workers with machines but unlike the
factory workers who were placed by
robots AI will affect different
professions including many in technology
itself I think that the biggest
immediate threat is probably two
white-collar workers we don't even need
these expensive sophisticated physical
robot to replace a white collar worker
oh all you need is a an algorithm that
can perform a knowledge based task a
report by Investment Bank Goldman Sachs
estimates 300 million jobs worldwide
could be disrupted by AI according to
several studies the occupations most
likely to be severely disrupted or even
eliminated by AI include software
engineers accountants administrative
assistants and journalists
Kevin Zhang whose company sells AI
augmented tools to employers says app
developers may become obsolete for
example if you want to find a ticket
which is a which is the cheapest air
ticket you can find just ask AI you
don't have to open a open a third-party
app to to match the price anymore AI
developers counter that for every job
lost to the technology multiple new ones
will be created by the new industries
that AI will open up we're very
optimistic that they're going to be
fantastic jobs in the future and the
current jobs can get much better
Educators say children need to start
learning about Ai and using it and it's
really important because those tools are
also evolving really fast so if they
don't start to use them now it's going
to be very hard for them to catch up
technology in its headlong Rush May
reshape the nature of work and Society
itself Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Santa
Clara California